des nuages de fumée après deux tirs de
missiles russes dans la zone de
l'aéroport près de lviv dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine l'aéroport n'est pas touché
mais jusqu'à présent cette zone n'était
pour l'instant épargnée par les combats
une usine est détruite les sirènes ont
retenti dans toute la ville à l'aube on
retrouve notre correspondant gulliver
craag sur place le gouverneur de la
région vient de ces petits vient de
s'exprimer quelles sont ses déclarations
oui alors d'abord maxime cause de qui il
y a en fait une personne qui a été
blessée dans une situation moyennement
grave mais pas de victimes de bon sens
il n'ya pas de mort est pour le moment
juste un blessé dans cette attaque
le gouverneur a dit que selon ses
informations les missiles avaient été
tirés depuis la mer noire et que les
systèmes de défense anti aérienne
ukrainienne ont pu abattre un certain
nombre d'émissaires de ces missiles mais
que quatre honte atteint leur cible qui
était donc cet atelier de réparation
d'avions près de l'aéroport de le vif
quelle est l'importance des dégâts de
l'hiver
selon le maire de la ville en tout cas
je pense que la patrie a été et plus ou
moins détruits ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que au moment de l'attaqué il n'y
avait pas de travailleurs sur place les
ukrainiens ne veulent pas donner
d'informations pour des raisons je pense
habitante stratégique sur s'il y avait
des avions sur place ou non mais c'était
un atelier qui pouvait servir à réparer
les avions de chasse de type mik on a
beaucoup discuté de la possibilité que
l'ukraine reçoit des avions de ce type
depuis la pologne ses avions au pourrait
peut-être besoin d'adaptation pour
servir dans les forces armées
ukrainiennes et donc et il paraît que
c'était une tentative par les russes de
détruire la possibilité d'utiliser cet
avion qui est
on voit que les rues c'est sec à
plusieurs endroits dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine et de cibler des bases
aériennes de rendre incapables les
forces de l'air ukrainien ça paraît être
leur stratégie principale dans le ces
attaques et qui ont lieu dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine c'est soit des bases
militaires soient des aéroports soient
des installations liées aux forces
aériennes pour la plupart à ces attaques
sont concentrées sur ses infrastructures
pour la